the israeli military has moved forces to
the gaza border as it prepares for a
potential ground incursion
both hamas and israeli forces are seeing
their casualty count rise
correspondent trey yingst joins us live
from the gaza israel border
as the violence threatens to escalate
into a full-blown
war good evening trey
shannon good evening fighting is
continuing tonight between israel and
gaza as the death toll
is rising tonight the israeli air force
is bombing targets throughout the gaza
strip
and earlier in the evening the artillery
units behind me were firing
shells at hamas and islamic jihad
positions the damage done to gaza in the
past 24 hours
will set the palestinian people back
years this level of conflict hasn't been
seen in the region
since operation protective edge in 2014.
more than 125 palestinians have been
killed so far
and hundreds more injured 31 of the dead
are children
on the israeli side the death toll
reached nine people today
the israeli military said that more than
2 thousand rockets have been fired from
gaza into israel
since monday the cross border violence
is no longer focused only here
and now across the region today 11
people were killed in the west bank
during clashes with israeli defense
forces
protests also erupted along the lebanese
and jordanian borders with israel
leading to the death of at least one
person there's a real sense
on the ground that things are unraveling
extremely quickly as prime minister
benjamin netanyahu said today
he's not done with the response from
israel towards hamas
as the group continues this evening to
fire rockets shannon
trey yingst in the middle east for us
tonight thank you trey hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else